Takashi and Matsuko are off
to a great start in their new life.
Let's give them a warm send-off.
Congratulations, Takashi and Matsuko.
I also offer warm wishes
to their parents and relatives.
Now, your prospects are boundless,
and you're embarking for the wide
open world under billowing sails.
Life, as they say, has its ups and downs.
At times, the waves may taunt you,
tossing you in their swells.
But take heart.
It's hard to stick with it
and make it on your own,
but even a couple of losers can survive
most things if they're together.
So listen, take my advice,
and have children as soon as you can.
Children are the best reason
for riding out life's storms.